hello there and welcome to council of
geeks my name is Nathaniel Wayne and I'm
joined tonight by Ryan Daly we were
gonna have Paul - but he's a bastard he
didn't come now he's sick we hope he
gets better so you'll notice a different
setup basically the green screen has
moved to a new permanent home and I'm
not moving it around anymore but it's in
a location where in the summers it's
really really hot in the winters it's
really really cold I'm willing to suffer
through that I'm not willing to play
guess who come on so what we're gonna
talk about on this one is we're
basically gonna go through the big geeky
releases of the summer 2016 now for the
purposes of this when I say summer we're
gonna start in May I know technically
summer doesn't start till June but my
mind summer movie season starts in May
which means we will not be talking
Batman V Superman or Civil War we're
gonna try and avoid the Marvel DC flame
war that seems to get worse overall
thoughts for this summer I didn't see a
lot and and I'm sure I've been the
majority of that because I think we'll
say that most of the summer tentpole
blockbuster releases underperformed in
terms of their box office yeah and
actually of the list I've compiled of
movies to talk about only one of them
did not at the very least underperform
if not flat-out bomb right so we'll
start with x-men apocalypse which was a
movie that I was well I was disappointed
in I didn't find offensively bad I came
out going okay that was a thing I kind
of think less of it every time I think
back on it though and I didn't have a
lot of good to say about the first time
I might overall take on it was it was
boring the audience sort of begged Brian
singer to come back to this property
after he had been gone for those two
ones in the mail so I think Fox's like
as long as Brian Sierra's doing this
we'll be fine we don't have to pay
attention this we don't have to you know
stand over a shoulder and make sure that
we don't have to do any quality control
and
so maybe I should by the time it was
over you're like has this left us in any
place different than where Days of
Future past left us and ultimately kind
of known not really I think they made
the mistake of thinking that if we make
the movie longer it will feel epic yeah
and yeah and I felt so bad for Oscar
Isaac because he's such a good and I've
even seen him be great in horrible
movies you know he was great in sucker
punch which is awful but he's so good
that but even he couldn't actually that
terrible makeup that they put him in and
these horrible generic lines that
somebody actually did a comparison and
some of them are word-for-word lifted
from the 90s cartoon I'm not saying that
to knock the 90s cartoon but you just
have different expectations when you
watch a cartoon versus go to the movies
so I do want to touch on also a possible
impact in what's next and I find it
slightly telling that they haven't
announced the next x-men movie in the
main franchise cuz I mean they they
setup apocalypse at the end of Days of
Future Passed and announced it almost
immediately right now obviously they've
still got their third Wolverine yep
going back earlier their Deadpool was a
huge hit for them so if they're looking
at those two things okay this is we're
gonna make our decision on the future of
the x-men franchise based on this year
Deadpool worked with the audience so we
already didn't we already know we're
getting Deadpool to they I don't think
it's official but they've said they're
looking into new mutants that was the
one I've heard within reason within the
last couple weeks is that they're still
developing that script and I think
that's what they want to do is some some
version of either x-force or new Muse or
make them different or make them similar
I don't know but it seems like that's
the way to go and I I think they should
I think they should retire the cast of
the x-men movies right now III think
yeah I don't think Jennifer Lawrence is
going to come back unless they pay her a
whole lot of money that they don't need
to pay her and I don't think any I don't
think the audience wants her to come
back anymore I'm not as emotionally
invested in the Deadpool and x-force
corner of the x-men property and
because of that that's actually what I
want them to focus on they can well they
can't let you down exactly
next up is one that I actually wanted to
see I didn't get to it um and that was
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles - out of
the shadows okay general consensus was
it wasn't objectively good but it was
better than the last one
do you were fan of the cartoon from the
90s the trailer was like this is a love
letter to that yeah it seemed to be it
seemed to have a better handle on being
dumb fun because the the first one ended
of just being dumb yeah and I've gone on
record various places saying that dumb
fun is actually really hard to do
correctly because usually just end up
with something insulting right it made
about half as much money that speaks to
an error in judgment on the studio's
part of pushing this thing when the
first one I don't I don't know what the
box office was for the fortunately it
did decent money it did pretty well but
the but this is sort of where I think
executives have a tendency to look at
the box office
and nothing else they look at that one
that meant that made money let's make
another and they don't get a gauge on
what people actually thought of it so
yes lots of people came out to see it
none of them liked them yeah a franchise
that isn't working I always kind of feel
bad when a franchise dies because in my
mind like it lost its chance to turn it
around and I kind of love an underdog
story it's never it's never too late to
stop sucking and I think we both love to
see a good Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
story yes we're fans of that property
yeah absolutely but unfortunately I
think that's probably the nail in the
coffin for that because because of the
way they chose to do it nyeeehhh
how CGI heavy it is I don't really know
if there's a way to cut the budget I
mean if I'm a microcosm for the general
audience that's why even somebody was
predisposed to liking Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles she said no that's not
something that interests me about
Warcraft didn't say me neither I I did
actually want to and this was even after
I heard it was supposed to be a hot mess
but I still wanted to see it because I
wanted to Val I wanted to validate the
stance that I have chosen to take that
you can't make a good movie out of a
video game which is an argument I've had
with Paul already it might get a sequel
is that because of its foreign
performance yes but there's an extra
wrinkle here it might get a sequel it
might be heavily financed with Chinese
money okay and it may not get a US
theatrical release okay because it made
so little money in the u.s. that the
movie would have been more profitable if
they just scrapped the US distribution
and just let it be primarily a Chinese
but an international film that's what I
wish they would do with the Transformers
franchise because the fourth
Transformers movie which I did not see
was the lowest performing domestically
at the domestic box office but I made a
billion dollars overseas a billion just
overseas and it was the lowest
performing domestically so yeah what US
US audiences have said Michael Bay we're
done with your version of transformers
let's be fair it's still made like 200
Warcraft made like 30 in the US but 30
total for yet $30 it's still 5 tickets
that was that nation overseas
so and that does I mean I know you don't
care cuz again you're not you're not a
gamer but it does kind of hinge it puts
a lot of weight on the shoulders of
Assassin's Creed I think there already
was a lot there already was a lot but
this puts more because at this point I
mean cuz ain't angry birds' is getting a
sequel which I figured it would every
birds was fine I actually saw I took my
daughter to it she had fun it was not
that bad but it were it's gonna be a
weird world where thee where people are
forced forced to hold up the Resident
Evil franchise and Angry Birds as the
pinnacles of this is as good is this
kind of gift for video game movies but
it will work out well for me because it
feels my argument that you can't make a
good move
the videogame and I will stand by that
until proven wrong and honestly I'd be
happy to be proven wrong I don't think
I'm gonna be not for a very long time
another one that I think we both missed
Independence Day resurgence yes and this
is what we needed poll here for this run
all actually saw this and I'm pretty
convinced that you went into the world
feeder what are we playing that weekend
what might be gone - I saw the original
Independence Day during the intervening
20 years yeah nothing made me think oh
man I really want to see more in that
word I mean not not only too little too
late
yeah but missing the star that everyone
remembers let's be honest that was the
movie that sent Will Smith into the
stratosphere and if there was anyone in
that movie you were gonna say I want to
see them again in this cuz Randy quits
character died right he does so yeah
yeah yeah the ships were bigger the
shipping ball okay here's something that
I looked up you know how in the original
they kind of went sort of purposefully
and I would say successfully generic
with the aliens it felt like it wasn't
ripping off anything because it was
ripping off everything sure yeah okay
well they went more specific with their
ripping off this time because there's an
alien queen who is significantly bigger
than all the other aliens mmm
there were ripping off ut yes and it
sets up a sequel like not hints at but
very blatantly sets up because
apparently there's some there's some
third faction there's some other race of
benevolent aliens that like after the
Queen the Queen gets killed at the end
but the mothership is still alive and
that goes away then the benevolent
aliens are like come with us into space
so we can end this fight well maybe when
I'm 65 that'll be a piece I I don't
think that's gonna happen because this
one did not do
my question ethically internationally it
it it did not make enough it couldn't
even justify like the way Warcraft good
was like all but it was this money it
made more internationally but that's
simply because there were more theaters
for it to play and then there were
domestically ghostbusters yeah so it was
fine it was it was fine which i think is
is sort of the problem because the
people who prejudge didn't pre hated it
were disappointed that it didn't it
wasn't as bad as they wanted to yeah and
the people who immediately rushed to its
defense and said no you're all wrong
this is a really great thing well kind
of over selling it because in a war
wasn't that good it I enjoyed I had a
good time watching it but as I was
watching it there kept being these
things that would just kind of take me
out of it and just say it could have
been better if they hadn't done that
most of those were the cameos by the
original performers I think every time I
saw Bill Murray or Dan Aykroyd or
Sigourney Weaver I was like mmm
the dead cast member had the most
dignified cameo geez
so they actually tell you everything
yeah I wanted it to be successful
I wanted it to make its money because I
thought if they can get a sequel most of
these problems can be corrected and they
can push this somewhere where I would
like to follow it like to see it go so I
was hoping that it would get a sequel
but it's not looking good they can look
at it as a loss leader and say you know
what we believe in this we think it
could do better on the second run if we
if we tweak these things they might like
the ball and say we believe in this the
power of this franchise we might retool
it a little bit but we will make another
one in three years they could do that I
wanted this to be better and I've seen a
lot of people you know online and in
certain circles that that I operate in
who have big look this is a movie about
for women and you know none of them are
in an active
relationship with a man and when they're
talking with each other it's never about
men and you know all these things are
like they're just hanging out there in
some business and they're making their
own way and I look at that and go that's
all great but I wish we could have had a
better movie that did all that those
positive things which I'm all in favor
of don't make it a better story don't
make it a better now don't make it
better characters that reminds me of
people who defend the Transformers
movies by going look it's huge giant
robots smashing each other on the screen
why isn't that awesome I'm like yes but
this is a lousy version of that
inherently awesome thing right now
Ghostbusters is better than the
Transformers movies but I feel that same
way when when I get into discussions of
its actual quality with people how much
credit can you give it just for being a
positive feminist movie like is that
yeah I'll give it all the credit
deserves buddy but I'm not saying to
overlook like quarry problem right
because of that cuz then does it get a
free pass not because it does things
that by this we really should come to
expect that in movies then it shouldn't
be a big deal that we can get a movie
about four strong women in this kind of
position high agreement but the nature
is that that is sort of a revolutionary
concept in movies right now does this
put more pressure on Wonder Woman I mean
is was the pressure already built on big
stuff at DC movie there's three movies
that as each of these things fails
there's three movies right now that are
carrying a lot of weight as far as
whether we will continue to see female
lead 10 polls and that is Wonder Woman
ghost in the shell' and Captain Marvel
and for each one of those that sinks
it's gonna put that is going to increase
the pressure on whichever ones are left
which is not fair and it's stupid but
it's it's because the pressure should
already be on those movies just to be
good quality movies it's it feels so
weird for me to listen for this position
because I grew up watching The
Terminator and alien movies which had
these female action heroes so to be 10
15 20 years later I was like why is this
a hard pill to swallow like why is this
I don't
Oh Star Trek yes Star Trek beyond which
I enjoyed I didn't love and has
underperformed compared to the previous
one that said I've seen a lot and I've
heard a lot from a lot of people who are
bigger friends bigger fans of Star Trek
as a franchise than I am who really
loved it and I understand why because
it's evocative of the actual of an
actual episode of the classic series but
a lot of just didn't quite come together
for me the villain I like the idea of
but he didn't quite work for me I feel
like we're missing a middle movie as the
opening narration established that
Captain Kirk is burning out on his run
on his five-year deep-space mission but
this first movie we've seen about a
five-year deep-space mission can we have
one movie where he's having fun
doing the thing that he spent two movies
being excited about doing we have to
jump right to he's jaded about it
already and that was one of the way that
I heard that that into darkness was a
horrible middle chapter for these three
movies or that this one should have been
the sequel to the 2009 Trek in terms of
a franchise now I like into darkness
totally a lot better than than many
people seem to but if we're looking at
overall franchise if you got to remove
one that's the one you should remove I
kind of felt the same way I was like I
liked it I didn't love it there were
things I could see where the great movie
was in this but they made a few missteps
and there were things that didn't
connect with me the villain that entire
plot there were a lot of elements that
just weren't catchy
however it was a movie where after I saw
the more I thought about it the more I
kind of found myself liking things and
liking the feeling that the movie gave
me and it was one that I wish I had seen
a second time
if I had had more time with the
opportunity I would have liked to go
back and see that a second time in the
theater it was one that felt very much
like an old Star Trek episode I had that
great spirit that sense of fun
unfortunately I think a lot of the
audience that would have responded to
this movie didn't go see it because they
saw other two movie they thought they
were never gonna get it right I heard
from things I've talked to Star Trek
fans who just said now I'm not gonna see
it and they just it was because they
didn't like the previous movie like they
didn't they especially didn't like it's
darkness some of them didn't like the
old man Trek as much but he just didn't
feel like this one connects and I think
that's unfortunate and I wonder if some
of that is it's in the marketing because
if I mean the comparison I would make
would be to look at the most recent Star
Wars movie mm-hmm which and the one
that's coming out - everything about the
marketing of that is like look how much
it looks like the old ones from the 70s
and 80s so all of the fans were burned
out by the prequels in the 90s and early
2000s who's like I'm never gonna watch
another Star Wars movie again they see
that that would okay I see what you're
doing here you you're really making a
look like whereas the new Star Trek felt
like I'm in an episode of the original
series but if you just looked about at
the trailer and we talked about it yet
trailer it was all the Beastie Boys song
it was all rock and roll fast
motorcycles and I was like okay looks
like a JJ Abrams music video this
doesn't look yeah cold truck so there
was a there was a disconnect between the
film that they delivered in the
marketing and I haven't feeling maybe
what happened was they made a movie that
would be more appealing to the old fans
and then marketing took those old fans
for granted I'm not gonna say the movie
did but I have a feeling that maybe the
marketing arm once assumed that the
family go if they don't come no matter
what let's let's get you know the young
hip Fast and Furious sure crowd in not
realizing that the people that the movie
had been made to appeal more to saw that
and went forget right last one Suicide
Squad
I liked it more than Batman V Superman
if only for sense of fun I think from a
technical storytelling level it is just
as much of a mess as
Batman V Superman was without hyperbole
I liked root canal better than Batman vs
Superman so I went in there expecting it
to be a bad messy movie I didn't hate it
but I didn't liked it
one character that I thought I was okay
I buy her because she said me speak
faithful is Amanda Waller and then
Amanda Waller has this turn in the
middle movie where she likes to shoot
more people yeah that I was like wait a
minute wait a minute that Amanda Waller
doesn't she's not a killer who's like
just going to murder people to protect
her own ass that's not who she is
the further everybody was like oh the
first half-hour is great the way it
introduces characters I feel like we got
three introductions for all the primary
characters in the span of like 20
minutes we kept on enchanting us the the
assault on Arkham anime movie did
effectively the same intro bits for
every character did the whole thing in
five minutes and did it better yeah
there's a lot of very fundamental things
that you just haven't gone well just put
that cuz like think about it Captain
Boomerang throws to my memory two
boomerangs right neither would you do
much of anything Deadshot shoots a lot
of people but does not do a single trick
impossible shot
not once one when he's taking out like
the gangster but it's even that is not
really impressive no it does like a
ricochet shot nothing nothing to spend
up he doesn't do any amazing oh my god
behind the shots katana has a sword that
sucks holes and we do not see it's not a
single soul I think you could take her
out of the movie and nothing changes you
you could take off you could take the
Joker out of the movie and nothing
changes your head somewhat less let's
actually talk about that Joker for a
minute now a lot of people have worked
on it I I actually can't make a call on
the character in the performance because
the character was so poorly integrated
and so superfluous to everything going
on that I actually don't think it
matters how good the poor or bad the
performance was it was never gonna work
I
want him to get a chance to do it again
because I want to see him where he
actually matters to the story and it
makes sense that he's there and the
character is used well so that I can
actually judge the performance because
otherwise I feel I feel like it's unfair
I feel like I feel like all that all the
effort certainly all the press went
around the character the
characterization of the Joker and the
way he lost himself in playing in the
quirks and the tattoos in the whatever
but almost no thought was put into how
why is he actually here from a narrative
perspective why is he important I feel
like nobody thought about that at all I
I think ultimately how little time they
gave him to write the thing is what
kills it more than anything else because
I think that's part of it I also think
how little how little they gave him the
movie in post-production s well that's
that's the other big deal that's that's
something I was gonna come back to
because it's obviously but you can tell
it's been reconfigured in the editing
room because they make a room like you
can tell that it's supposed to be a
reveal that flag was sleeping with the
Enchantress
but we know that within five minutes of
the movie started and that's obviously
just all been rejiggered because the way
it's presented that was we obviously
weren't supposed to know that yeah as
far as how the script was written right
but I had this general thought overall
and I said I was gonna try and avoid
Marvel vs. DC but I'm gonna poke the
bear what it feels like is both Marvel
and DC have the ways that they want to
control the product I think the
difference is Marvel does it on the
front end DC does it on the back end and
by that I mean Marvel when they are
lining up the talent in the first place
go these are the things we need this to
be are you okay with that and that's why
we lost say a great right but we lost
him before the movie started shooting so
that they could bring so that and that's
why ant-man while I feel it's a lesser
Marvel movie didn't completely fall down
on its face because the person who they
got
to actually make it was on the same page
as them what I feel like DC does is they
bring in talent and then this certainly
felt like the case from Batman V
Superman and you know how Suicide Squad
it feels like they brought in talent may
gave them maybe a time frame and said do
whatever you want but then try to force
it to be what they want to be in the
editing room as opposed to doing all
that kind of control at the front end
and then just letting the movie happen
since the end of phase 1 most of the
directors that Marvel has gotten have
come out of TV yeah these are journeyman
directors who are used to working in
these type of constraints within the
sandbox okay they're here for this
chapter that you this they're on this
type thing and they're just they're just
plenty and part of a whole picture
they understand that they know how to
work with that and that helps nothing
feel more or less seamless across 13
movies now yeah whereas DC is looking
for visionary directors who have these a
ton of things they make war movies and
these epic sagas and all these things
like that but then they freak out when
the reviews come in for the last movie
and they overreact to certain things and
they're like you know the doggy's didn't
wait the last week so we have to do this
to this one before someone accused me of
BV being a Marvel fan boy and being in
Disney's pocket oh I wish Disney if you
want to actually pay me for my opinion I
would happily cash that check but just
to make the point that that's not what
I'm doing what Disney does will
absolutely give you a more homogenized
problem what and what DC does could
potentially get you a more out of the
box
mean that we never expected that product
but it hasn't and when that process
fails it fails much harder because when
a Marvel movie fails you get Iron Man to
it I can't I didn't love it but I can't
get I can't hate it either I can't get
worked up about it and that's about as
bad as you get out of Marvel's process
DC when it goes bad it goes much worse
not potentially with DC's process you
could you could theoretically get
something better and more
visionary more original than anything
Marvel has or possibly ever could put
out but it hasn't happened yet
I mean arguably it happened with Nolan
but III would still say I like the Dark
Knight better than any of the Marvel
movies I've seen and I can I'll give you
that jumping back to suicide because
this was a major point this was the one
that has actually done well at the box
yes it has spiked pretty again Universal
negative pretty critical reviews yes
much in the same way Batman vs Superman
had negative critical responses before
the movie came out Suicide Squad had
just a slew of bad press before the
movie came out doesn't seem to have
mattered much I and honestly I chalk
that up to the one thing that I say it
has over Batman be super fun which is
fun I think that if a movie is fun
maybe not critics but audiences can be
much more forgiving that didn't save
Batman V Superman because it was so dour
and so self-serious that when you failed
to deliver something coherent and
there's no sense of fun that's the
nobody goes back to second time yeah
possible that we're thinking about this
more than we should be yo that's a weird
shot there it's almost as if you stated
the entire premise of this YouTube
channel and podcast feed but not so we
don't get that so I guess that we had
about wraps up summer of 2016 so I guess
we will wrap it up on that note um why
do you anything you feel like plugging
you've got so many things but I know
some of them are ending and I am the
host of The Secret Origins podcast which
reviews The Secret Origins comics
published by DC in the 80s just sorry
September and October the last four
episodes of that show we're ramping up
to a massive huge conclusion that's
gonna be really exciting out a lot of
great guests you're not one of them so
sad love a lot of guests that I could
afford and
your last check bounced any of you also
got a few other podcasts on the fire
water Network give me those star wars
she talks about Star Wars franchise and
power of fishnets The Black Canary and
Zatanna podcast so what were your
thoughts on the summer of 2016
geeky movies did you like them did you
see some of the ones we didn't and are
shaking your fist going you would have
liked it have you seen it or were you as
done with it by the end as we were
whatever you your thoughts were go ahead
and drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it don't forget to
Like subscribe you can listen to the
Council of geeks podcasts on iTunes and
stitcher you can follow me on Twitter at
council of geeks and until next time
this council is adjourned
I think you're ringing do you want to
redo that